[Music]
good idea for a q a series
uh thanks mike this is exactly what i'm
gonna do
you know if that were possible maybe
i'd say hip hop is probably the biggest
for me i listen to that the most
but i'll listen to just about anything
the one type of music i have trouble
with is metal
basically my little brother making fun
of me for saying too much about a movie
i thought it would be funny to go the
opposite direction
you're talking how long a critic should
take i have no idea i don't know if i
put a limit on it in any direction i
think you should say whatever you have
to say if it's longer than the album so
be it but
you know yeah that sounds about right
i like the idea of a one word review of
movies or albums that makes me laugh
but i figured if i did only one word i'd
run out of words pretty quick
yeah i've always been messing around
with youtube just making videos for my
family and stuff nothing ever took off
like this though
i'm not going to answer this but i think
it's really funny the way you said main
job as if this is now a job for me
definitely always been a part of my life
and i'm not a musician but i do play
some instruments
oh yeah i'll give you that right after i
give you my social security number what
no
i'm not sure if i'll do a review of it
but cassandra jenkins an overview
of phenomenal nature might be number one
right now
i don't think i can answer this question
i don't really think in these terms if
there's an album i don't like i just
kind of move on uh
no but i do have an idea for a long one
coming up so stay tuned
i'd say either a scene from annihilation
or that video of the monkey getting a
haircut
well most of the ones i've reviewed i've
listened to for years but sometimes you
know you listen to it once and that's
enough
maybe i get an idea for how to review it
the first time i listen to it maybe i
never do
absolutely not and that's because what
i'm doing is a parody of music
journalism
now i just put my name into the wu-tang
clan name generator it's sort of an
homage to childish gambino now i don't
go in
second intervals i listen to the whole
album
not a flannel this is a fleece i got it
at kohl's
[Music]
great question here's the first album i
ever owned here's the first vinyl i ever
bought
here's the album that opened my eyes to
music and here's the album that made me
take hip-hop seriously
you know favorites is such an impossible
question for me and the idea of doing
that in 10 seconds is crazy but
you know i can just give you some albums
that i love
really hard for me to do favorite
artists i'm just going to scroll some
over the video at this point
question here's two that i really love
looking at and if i could hold it up
uh iron maidens number of the beast
[Music]
i can't answer this in 10 seconds i
might actually do some long form videos
of my favorite albums of each of the
last two years
wow another hard question it's between
these two
and it just kind of depends on the day i
guess
well if i get 10 seconds i can give you
my top three tree of life
12 angry men adventureland
i don't know why this question gets
harder when you get older but my younger
self would say green
my thoughts on beanie babies uh boy what
was that all about am i right what
what
my review of 2020 generally i would say
it's the
shortest and longest year of my life
spent a lot of it indoors
stuck in the house
[Music]
i don't know i just i like music i i
listen to music
albums is my preferred way of listening
so i just
try to listen to at least a couple
albums a day
i appreciate this and yeah i think it'll
be fun to try some longer things so
hopefully you like this video it's a bit
longer
[Music]
uh yeah i love music it's one of my
favorite things